now I love animation
I love animation because in the world of
animation you could be anything you want
to be
you're a fat woman you can play a skinny
princess if you're a short wimpy guy you
can play a tall gladiator if you're a
white man you can play an Arabian Prince
and if you're a black man you can play a
donkey or a zebra
well I can't play white my god now I
hate when people go on TV and tell you
how hard it is to do jet animations like
oj is such hard work it's so hard to an
animation getting into character no no
ups is hard work okay
stripping wood is hard work I've done
some animation and here's how easy it is
it's the easiest job in the world I go
in a booth and I go oh what's the line
and the guy goes it's time to go to the
store and then I go it's time to go to
the stove and then you like that oh we
can move all that and then I go what's
the next line I got who's getting dark
outside it's getting dark outside and
then they give me a million dollars
here are the nominees for Best Animated
Feature Film Canton Paris directed by
Harlan Daniel and John Liu Phillipe
Scioli Chico and Rita directed by
Fernando Trueba and Javier Mariscal Kung
Fu Panda 2 directed by Jennifer Randall
Puss in Boots directed by Chris Miller
Rango directed by Gore Verbinski and
yester goes to wrangle over that's Kate
feature film director Gore Verbinski
said it wasn't difficult to switch from
live-action to computer animation since
it's used so much and big
action-adventure movies this is his
first Academy Award and nomination thank
you so much this is uh crazy
um someone asked me if this film was for
kids and I don't know but we're
certainly created by a bunch of
grown-ups acting like children and we
just had the best time I want to thank
the real world chameleon mr. Johnny Depp
and the entire cast for coming out and
I'm playing you know and to the artist
crash McCreary Jim Burkett Hal Hickel
Tim Alexander John old everybody at
blind wink and ILM who put so much
passion into every frame and to the
early believers John Logan
Graham King Brad gray and everyone at
Paramount who who really let us try
something different and my beautiful
wife and my family who inspire me every
day with their smiles and laughter it
doesn't get any better than this
thank you
[Applause]